and let's not forget this is rated page
13 for uh brief sexuality first marvel
movie to have to have some brief
sexuality that brief meaning fast dose
implying homosexuality yeah we saw his
husband over his shoulder yeah and that
was the brief sexuality yeah
acknowledgement of sexuality that's when
disney exec stand up and go we did it
guys
sure they're really happy to be having
us
[Music]
what is up there reject nation thank you
so much for clicking on this video if
you end up enjoying it leave leave a
like yeah so we're gonna watch some tv
spots here release from marvel
entertainment for eternals we are going
to go watch eternals this coming monday
and hopefully if i think it's a
masterpiece we can get quoted on one of
their tv spots that's the key i get that
pull quote
baby we got protect team change and
return i threw them all in a final
cutter he's gonna play it all at once
[Music]
we're eternals
who came here to protect humans
dad i saw him on tv
[Music]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
humanity once believed
[Music]
the turtles assembled
[Music]
great question
until now
hey nobody interfering
the mcu
hello hey who's your gardener
[Music]
[Music]
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked
yeah carissa's definitely gonna be a bad
guy yeah
i'll watch this let's just go icarus bad
i could feel it yeah feel the turn
coming good guys wear capes he would
have said he wears a cape if he's a good
guy it's funny when you think about how
long it took captain america to finally
get the words avengers assemble in there
one movie yeah i noticed up here
turtle's a symbol eternal's assemble and
you know what else i found fascinating
these spots capitalized way more on the
familiar marvel humor
than any of the actual trait like the
actual trailers maybe have like one or
two moments i remember like with fast
dose at the end
yeah the vibranium table or something
but it's not they've always been so like
poetic and uh symbolic and epic looking
all this gravity galaxy yeah they
capitalized way more on the action this
made it feel more familiar yes you know
what i mean cause i thought they were
gonna like kind of really just commit to
the
the heft the the seriousness of it all
getting more of the comedic interludes
here or there it feels appropriate
considering that they are a family
technically family will banter and
bicker with each other react to their
idiosyncrasies like look at them how the
weird
they're function relatable getting each
other's asses about things so yeah that
seems fun is andrew and joe lee doing
her uh british accent again it seems as
though that damn british accent she does
when i was a youngin it took me a while
to realize she wasn't british wow she
had your fool she had me fooled in laura
croft tomb raider
i was not at all distracted by anything
i was just the accent yeah that drew me
to her i mean she definitely got what
seems like more dialogue and and yeah
even a couple of those marvel humor
moments like it it made her in a way to
me feel a bit more like a character like
i could get a better sense of who this
character might be in action whereas
like the main trailers do make her
mostly feel like a stoic eternal being
which is fitting but at the same time
you know spending time with them and
knowing their history they're going to
be more personable than that and then
their tv spots so what can you do it's
like you're gonna give the most punchy
images that you can and yeah this is
mostly the action and the main thing i
hope for is that they do spend as much
time on the philosophy and on the you
know moral
uh conundrums that are at play here the
action does look really cool i love the
designs of their powers and whatnot but
you know in these trailers it kind of
just makes them look like a team with
powers like we're used to seeing you got
some people with energy blasts and some
people with weapons and they can all
kind of you know run and jump fast and
far these don't feel quite as unique
other than just the visual palette and
the settings and stuff i mean it does
look beautiful i'm not gonna lie it
looks beautiful i'm still excited and
they gave like ajax the lines about
thanos there i think it's kind of
capitalizing more on what you were
talking about with kind of the dilemma
they've imposed like do we listen to our
celestials yeah or do we get involved
and help with the fight against humanity
because that seems to be the reoccurring
theme of debate of [ __ ] or shouldn't we
get involved in the fight now it sounds
like ajax is all four and so i'm kind of
wondering if icarus will be forward or
not because i imagine this is a long
movie the fight scenes they keep showing
us like with the deviants all seem to be
pulling from the similar same fights
with their landscapes not really being
populated either with buildings it's
like a lot of it seems like very
isolated like desert beach yeah oceanic
places but nothing there's like there's
one shot they keep going to in the city
so maybe that's from the finale or very
early on it has to be one of the other
you have like these places where you're
not really seeing the consequences of
the potential suffrage that can occur
from one of their fights yeah you know
what i mean yeah usually a lot of the
big fights take place is like their
surroundings seem very limited that's
one thing that keeps kind of making me
wonder what the vibe of this will
ultimately be like how isolated will
they be from the rest of the human
population while these fight scenes are
taking place or are they intentionally
leaving out so much from the trailers
because for strong chi they did they
shocked you they left out so much i was
really glad they did so i imagine
that'll be a similar case here and let's
not forget this is rated page 13 for uh
brief sexuality first marvel movie to
have to have some brief sexuality that
brief meaning fast dose implying
homosexuality yeah we saw his husband
over his shoulder yeah and that was the
brief sexuality yeah
acknowledgement of sexuality that's when
disney execs stand up and go we did it
guys
feels good right there on my back sure
they're really happy to be having us
i know aren't you guys thrilling you're
just throwing the right wants to go it's
the masterpiece get on twitter
brief sexuality more like sexuality
throughout oh my god wouldn't stop with
the gayness in my face
i would be thrilled to see that marvel
movie honestly i'm excited though i mean
i've heard nothing but amazing things
about this in terms of the upcoming
movies for all the like 2021 before
black widow the one that feige seems to
edify the most has been eternals so i
feel like it's gonna be something pretty
special and that gives me hope for the
limited range of footage we've seen is
they gotta be just hiding all of the
crazier stuff for the actual experience
which i am cool with i'm not guys leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell hit that like button let's do
a pic
anisa oliva when we hit 900k subscribers
you were the first person to do an
instagram story about us you
monitor us and make sure we are
succeeding and believe it or not most of
our patrons don't want us to no but you
want us to succeed and i feel great
about that a lot of patrons pledge to
watch us fail entirely yeah you are the
one of like two people who actually
wants to see us succeed you're eternal
anissa we will hug you 900 000 we love
you
900 000
like marvel love you three thousand
three hundred thousand times better
let's meet up
and hug it out
i could just yeah i can just feel how
about you lean girl parties
[Music]